hey everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
the Ingram angle from Washington tonight
thanks as always for joining us on a
very busy Monday
the lies that blind that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
all right Joe Biden is a congenital liar
about little things and big things
Senator Joseph Biden who held a news
conference Wednesday to announce an end
to his campaign for the presidency in
1988. uh I have to choose between
running for president
and doing my job there will be other
opportunities for me to campaign for
president
but there will not be many other
opportunities for me to influence
President Reagan's choice I do it with
Incredible reluctance
and it makes me angry and I am no less
frustrated
for the environment of President
difficult to let the American people
measure the whole Joe Biden
and not just misstatements wait wait
misstatements false they weren't
misstatements in a presidential debate
about a month earlier Senator Biden
lifted phrases and even mannerisms from
a speech by British labor party leader
Neil kinnick now it was egregious and
the lies of course kept coming
let's start telling the truth number one
you take all the truths out you better
have helicopters ready to take those 3
000 civilians inside the green zone
where I've been seven times and shot at
no he wasn't shot at well then came the
revision
the lies never stopped and I could spend
the entire hour of the Ingram angle
cataloging them and when he became
president of course he lied about stupid
stuff that's easily checkable like the
price of gasoline
the most common price of gas in America
is 3.39 down from over five dollars when
I took office
okay but gas was only two dollars and 39
cents when Biden took office
and then totally because of his anti-oil
and gas policies it hit highs of more
than five dollars as we all recall
now he lies about the deficit too saying
he reduced it by 1.7 trillion when his
spend the palooza increased it we all
know that
of course the lies on the border those
are legendary gallup's new survey says
that 70 percent of Americans say it's a
crisis at the border or a major crisis
including 55 percent of Democrats
Biden's Catch and Release policies
they've resulted in approximately get
this 7 million illegal Crossings
according to one congressman and
according to the Customs and Border
Protection 144
000 encounters at the Border in just the
month of June
so human smuggling is now a billion
dollar a year business
well the middle class in America may be
pessimistic but at least the cartels are
happy
and lately he's been lying a lot about
bidenomics
our plan is working and one of the
things I'm proud is that is working
everywhere not just in the coast and big
cities like previous recoveries this
time investment is working in fact he's
being built and jobs being created
happening in Rural America so Heartland
all across America
well it's not working it doesn't work
for the average person unless you define
success as a scenario under which the
bidens get rich and the average working
person gets poorer
yeah one of the most egregious lies is
about to be exposed for the world to see
I've never spoken to my son about his
overseas business I have never discussed
with my son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period there is zero zero
zero zero evidence of any assertion
being made how involved were you in your
thugs trying
to take down text message were you
sitting there before you involved no
get off my lawn
and of course the Apple doesn't fall far
from that tree
not one investigative body not one
serious journalist has ever accused has
ever come to the conclusion that I did
anything wrong or that my father did
anything wrong did you and your father
ever discuss Ukraine no as I said the
only time it was after a news account it
wasn't a discussion in any way there's
no but to this no we never did your dad
said I hope you know what you're doing I
hope you know what you're doing I do and
I said I do and that was literally the
end of our discussion
and now it looks like friend and former
business partner Devin Archer is set to
testify finally after trying to avoid it
before the house oversight committee and
he's going to spill the beans on then
Vice President Biden's contacts with his
son's foreign business interests
now according to reporting from the New
York Post Miranda Define who she's going
to join us shortly Archer is going to
testify that Hunter put his dad on the
phone at least two dozen times with
these individuals from various foreign
entities
so how did this work in practice well
it's kind of like this well late on
Friday December 4th 2015 two ukrainians
joined Hunter and Archer at the Four
Seasons in Dubai a senior barisma
executive asked Hunter at that meeting
can you ring your dad well Hunter did
exactly that and put his dad on
speakerphone then introduced the
ukrainians that were there by name and
said to everybody on the call
they need our support
now recall that both Hunter and Mr
Archer landed Plumb jobs on the board of
barisma even though Hunter's energy
experience seemed to be limited to how
he felt as a person when he was doing
lines of coke with random hookers
also recall that Hunter's other business
partner Tony bobolinski had also
confirmed the big guy's conversations
when Hunter was trying to impress
clients I've heard Joe Biden say that
he's never discussed business with
Hunter
that is false
I have firsthand knowledge about this
because I directly dealt with the Biden
family including Joe Biden on May 2nd
2017 the night before Joe Biden was to
appear at the Milken conference
I was introduced to Joe Biden by Jim
Biden and Hunter Biden
at approx at my approximately hour-long
meeting with Joe that night we discussed
the Biden's history
the Biden's family business plans with
the Chinese with which he was plainly
familiar at least at a high level
that was during the 2020 campaign
imagine if the Press had actually cared
now the White House Press spokeswoman
was asked about Archer's upcoming
testimony and now listen closely to What
She Said Today listen closely to her
response the White House and the
president still stand behind his comment
that he's never been involved and has
never even spoken to his son about his
so I've been I've been asked this
question a million times the answer is
not going to change the answer Remains
the Same the president had was never in
business with his son I just don't have
anything else to add
what
in business well technically technically
that may be true it's kind of like what
the meaning of the word is is right but
practically that looks just like another
lie
the astonishing thing here though for
all of us who've known for years that
the bidens were on the take right
no one could explain how the bidens got
so rich no one and of course our press
never pressed the question why
and we know the Democrat Party simply
doesn't care if Joe Biden took millions
in bribes there is no set of evidence
that will ever be strong enough ever
to get them to say enough
but compare their reaction to Trump's
phone call with zelinski
could not ignore what the president did
he gave us no choice so it wasn't any
change of mind I always said
we will follow the facts where they take
us and when we see them we will be ready
and we are ready
well of course she was talking about
impeachment now once again the angle
expects the regime media to cover for
the bidens yeah even after Archer
testifies
but in the process they're going to do
enormous damage to their own credibility
even worse than they've already done
but I'm going to ask this question again
why is it so important for them to save
Joe Biden's career
look he's a crook and he's a terrible
president
I know there are a lot of you out there
who are cynical about Washington I don't
blame you one bit
but if this story is true and it sure
looks like it that he's been sitting in
on these calls to help his son's clients
while he was vice president that he was
meeting with his business contacts that
is a massive scandal in a flashing neon
sign that says America is for sale
oh and follow you high and mighty
politicians who've been lecturing us on
Dignity and respect and norms
many of you of course were trashing
Donald Trump as you said all that I'm
talking about people like Mitt Romney
Liz Cheney murkowski and McConnell
well where's all that emotion on this
scandal
hardly a peep
and I think we know why because most of
them would rather have Biden in the
white house for four more years even
with all the damage he's done and all
the damage he will do
then to see Trump back in
the Democrats don't care about any of
this the moderate Republicans they
haven't said much
so the only question left is what do the
voters think
do they care
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else